All right, hi everyone, my name is Artur,
I work on the Google security team as an engineer
and what my team does is we try to make sure
that we don't have security vulnerabilities
in our products, as you might know Google
has a lot of web application, web-apps are
a big part of our world and we work with external
researchers that get paid for findings vulnerabilities
in our products when we miss something.
This puts us in a position where we find out
a lot about new patterns and flaws that can
affect the security of our web applications,
because a lot of are web-apps are built using
open sources frameworks like angular and other
ones, we learn about patterns that can affect
security and your web-apps possibly as well,
right after we update code we often get new
data about some security flaws.
My hope for this talk is to share some of
this with you and I'm very, I'm very happy
that Anand Vemuri hopefully already scared
you a little bit when it comes to security
and the impact of cross-site scripting, so
I my intent is to build up on this a little
bit and show you some angular-specific examples.
Before I start, can you guys raise your hand
if you know what angular is or if you have
written angular code in the past - ok, this
is music to my ears.
Ok, so let's get started.
This is a security talk, this is JSConf so
I will not tell you anything about securing
your database, or your back up systems, so
not going to talk about server security at
all, we're going to talk about client security
and client security here is making sure that
the users of your web applications don't get,
cannot get compromised or attacked by evil
websites or networks.
Client security is a fairly broad area as
well and, you know, if you want to have a
secure website you should have HTTPS and prevent
a bunch of other things, but we're not going
to talk about that in general either, I will
focus on the biggest threat that is sort of,
as an industry or web application developers
we have been facing since web-apps have existed.
I know this is a subjective view but, at least
at Google this is something that we are super
concerned about.
So, cross-site scripting.
Also the other thing is that for the other
flaws, the other common things that we are
worried about in web applications we have
relatively a good way of preventing them,
it might not be super straightforward, but
if you want to prevent eavesdroppers getting
access to your users' data in your web app,
you can deploy HTTPS and security engineers
will tell you what to do, it will be ok.
For cross-site scripting it's not usually
that simple, there are no panaceas that will
prevent your developers from introducing cross-site
scripting bugs.
If you have been here for Anand Vemuri's talk,
most of you have, this is cross-site scripting,
cross-site scripting got introduced if you
have a HTTP parameter that you output to your
page without any escape, right, so you have
a script, you have a get parameter, you write
it out and then what an evil website can do,
they can point to that URL and make your user
execute an evil script.
One example of an evil script was something
that Anand Vemuri showed, basically someone
gave a webcam permissions to your website,
they can transparently enable it and sort
of spy on your users, but it
goes much beyond that actually.
So what the evil code can do once it's injected
into your origin, your domain, it has full
access to everything your user can do in the
web app, if you think of rich ecosystems of
application, such as any major provider, Google,
Facebook, Twitter, most of your apps, the
HorseDrawingTycoon app that Curtis will talk
about in the next session, if you are an,
attacker and can inject evil code you can
get access to everything a web application
has and you can attack other apps that live
in the same domain as a cross-site scripting
bug.
We worry about the fact you can persist your
access as an attacker after you exploit cross-site
scripting for a given user.
What this means, even two months later, even
after the developer closes the cross-site
scripting vulnerability the attacker might
still be able to retain some access to the
web app, so that is super scary.
So, but you know, the good thing is that traditionally
as JavaScript developers we did not have to
worry too much about, you know, the various
ways in which you can introduce XSS into the
web-apps, when you purely write JavaScript
code there are only a few APIs that might
be able to, that could lead to cross-site
scripting, so things like setting inner HTML,
document.write, when you set HTML, when you
set JavaScript URIs on window open navigation
and so on, maybe five years ago if you kept
all of those in mind when you were writing
your JavaScript code, you would be safe from
say 95% of the bugs that would otherwise introduced,
be careful with all the APIs.
The thing that is different these days, we
don't really write web applications that use
those primatives directly, it's fairly rare,
stuff like that rarely happens, it's rare
for modern well designed web application to
use document.write, there are circumstances
where you might have to do that, but it's
not that common.
The reason that's the case, there are many
new frameworks and many new APIs that were
introduced to make our lives easier, as part
of the big web frameworks, so we don't have
to use the bare metal - it does make our life
easier, it makes it easier to use the APIs
without really understanding, if you have
a framework that wraps around one of these
functions then you are still vulnerable to
the same class of issues, but even though
you have not written code that uses the dangerous
API directly.
So, one of the things that has been, one of
the frameworks that has become fairly popular
recently has been angular, to be honest I'm
sure that almost all of you know way more
about angular than I do, I'm not an angular
developer or Evangelist for that matter, I'm
a security engineer, I know enough to break
angular apps but not enough to build with
angular, but that's ok, hopefully if you don't
know too much about angular, I will show you
the bare things you need to understand, code
examples that we will talk about.
Angular is pretty popular, just in case you
forgot all about angular in the ten minutes
since I asked you if you know angular, this
is how it works, three short steps.
You include the angular JavaScript somewhere
on your page, then you write something that
looks like HTML, sort of, so, you know, you
write mark-up and you also have these ng-attributes
that allow your application to do the angular
magic, right, you can have loops, you can
have, you know, data-bindings, the must have
syntax that will be important in a few
minutes, it's not specific to angular, it's
one of the big users of moustache syntax,
the last thing is to behind the JavaScript
that you write for your controller, to the
appropriate DOM element that has all the bindings
and angular syntax, right, it's fairly straightforward
conceptually it allows really powerful, really
cool web applications to be built.
There is a lot of APIs, the template syntax
is very rich, you can do a lot with that,
there is components, a lot of APIs for requesting
data from the server and you know, really
lots of cool stuff you can look at examples,
it's great.
All right, so, you know, I've set it up a
little bit, you know angular, you know this
is an security talk, so what, what's the deal?
So, when you start using these frameworks
there are a lot of things that might look
to be, might seem to be very safe, but actually
when you, when you sort of look more closely
turns out there are subtle issues there.
So, the first issue that we have actually
run into several times in several of our applications
is what happens if you mix angular and surfer-side
template systems, so I hope that most if you,
when you generate mark-up on the server are
using a templatetime, as Anand Vemuri was
saying earlier, this is something that gives
you context escaping so you don't have to
do it manually because you need different
types of escaping, the template server will
take care of all of that for you.
In the past you would have a template, you
would render it and even if you had evil inputs
to your application, the template system would,
by default, just escape it, properly for the
context, at least if you are using a good
template system and most, most reasonable,
modern frameworks use those and you are fine.
So, ok, so what this problem really?
So this is what happens when you, when you
use a template system on the server-side and
angular.
The only difference here is that we have included
some angular elements in are template right,
we have the ng-app, but what happens is and
this is in the bottom code box, that the template
system will escape all your HTML meta characters,
you can't just inject HTML but your server-side
system knows much about the moustache system,
you if you allow this kind of output, angular
when it processes the page after it loads
it will do it's magic, try to find directives
in the angular controlled DOM element and
it will execute them.
What this means is that as an attacker you
might not be able to inject straight up mark-up,
but you can use angular data bindings, execute
arbitrary angular controller functions so
basically do anything that is defined in your
angular controllers and also the sort of really
big thing that, that is not often talked about,
is that it's possible to escape out of the
angular box, and once you can inject the moustache
since tax - if you go to the angular security
page they will tell you, you should not mix
client side and server-side templates, it
can lead to the interesting interactions between
the two, that will, that will - that can possibly
make your app vulnerable.
There are good reasons to do this, if you
retrofit angular into existing web applications
that are often generated alongside server-side
templates then you will have these issues.
Also if you want to pre-populate part of your
page with data the server knows about and
you want to avoid a separate call back to
get this data, it's sort of natural to do
this, it's one pattern that is surprisingly
interesting.
Ok so let's say we go about this, we create
our Angular part of the page statically we
don't have any server-side template generation
we just have a very simple application here,
which has just one image and alt tag and displays
the fav icon.
We have a controller, the controller has a
dangerous function but we're not executing
it so everything is fine, nothing to worry
about here.
So what happens if before we run Angular on
the page, we insert and we run another completely
innocuous JavaScript function, what this function
is doing is finding all the image elements
on the page, and it's adding an alt attribute
to every image it's probably a really crappy
use of the alt attribute you should never
do this but we're just adding some data image
from our site.
When the location is something that is controlled
in part by the user because you can open any
web page with location.hash, the URL fragment
at the end is something that the user controls
but the alt tag, the alt attribute it's not
async, it's normally if you do this nothing
bad will happen.
If you insert a script tag or HTML markup
it will not render it's just like a bit of
text, but what happens here when this interaction
appears, is before Angular is invoked after
our function runs, we will suddenly have this
bit of DOM where you have an alt attribute
which data so assuming that the attacker injected
a bit of Angular markup in the URL what Angular
sees when it tries to parse the page is an
alt attribute with a data binding.
It will look at it think ok well now there
is something for me I will execute it.
Again as an attacker, you are able to inject
arbitrary JavaScript and compromise the application.
So this is another example of an interaction
where before everything would have been safe,
but because you are using a client side powerful
framework you start having problems.
All right, so let me give you another example.
So one of the most powerful features of Angular
and other similar framework Ss are in includes
where you don't have to have all your HTML
syntax inline but you can include sub templates
and these templates will be rendered as part
of your application so it's really great.
It allows angular to fetch a little bit of
markup anywhere from the server, render it
in it's super useful.
So in here what we're doing is we have this
NG, including that is based on the scope of
the controller so when we set the template
URL variable we're saying this is just a pass
to an HTML file on our server.
So again nothing to worry about it's fine
the user language is controlled, by the user
possibly but it doesn't seem like there's
anything super wrong here.
Right?
Well hopefully by now you know that all the
examples are tricky, yes there is something
wrong and there is something bad that can
happen in this application.
So if the user can control this variable,
part of the URL from which Angular loads the
template what they can do is they can add
and this is actually very reminiscent of old
server where you have directory reversal you
are sometimes on the server able to read files
from different directories than you would
expect.
Here is the same but it's on the client.
So when this sort of
evil language variable is embedded as part
of the include value, what will happen is
that this URL is no longer pointing to/angular
templates/something it can point to a URL
on your website that redirects to a completely
external site that might be controlled by
the user.
Because under the hood what Angular is doing
is XML HTTP request if it replies with all
the cross origin headers the data that the
attacker supplies will now be include as part
of our application that can contain HTML and
arbitrary scripts.
Something that I should mention here is that
Angular does have a mechanism that will, that
by default prevent this from happening, but
Angular also considers anything under your
domain to be a trusted resource.
So to angular this URL/angular/templates,
this looks like a trusted resource, it points
to your web server it has no easy way of knowing
that eventually if the browser follows all
the redirects this can contain untrusted data.
So by default if you use those kind of patterns,
your application will be vulnerable.
So another example.
So, let's say that just hypothetically you
have a HorseDrawingTycoon application, and
you use JCP in that, complete hypothetical
HorseDrawingTycoon I am sure most of you are
familiar with JSONP, I am not sure why it's
called JSON, it doesn't look like padding
to me that's what it's called four few years
I guess the name stuck.
It's how you JSONP in angular there's a convenience
rapper for JSONP, you can call a HTTP object,
what happens is the URL you pass to this function
will be used as a script source if you think
about what that means you will not manually
ever write JavaScript code that says create
a document, create element script then as
a source assign evil.com to it, but when you
use the JSONP API in a way that's is commonly
used especially for restful APIs, you say
I want to load JSONP from my server, /app
then there is something that is potentially
controlled by the user.
A name of your object, or an identifier of
your object, and if you create a URL like
this, it's the same kind of pattern that we
just saw with the NG include example.
Basically if as part of the URL you have,
./you will fetch an open re-direct or from
an evil site.
Again now the evil application cannot respond
with HTML but it can respond with an evil
straight up JavaScript.
So maybe the JSONP API is not that common
but what is really common in angular applications
is the HTTP get API, any time you want to
retrieve something from your server or any
external resource you use HTTP get.
If you just want to load say JSON, not JSONP
but JSON or any other thing you generate from
the server you will have a very similar issue.
So this is actually a very common pattern
we see.
By itself if you just use HTTP get on a potentially
external untrusted resource it's not terrible
because what will end up happening is that
you will issue an XML HTTP request your application
will get the data but if it discards is or
does nothing with it you will be safe because
the data just by calling HTTP get you are
not doing anything that’s super scary but
what actually happens is that the data that
you obtain from the server, is used for something
later, like generating parts of the page.
So in here if we call inner HTML we assign
inner HTML us any of the data we have got
from what we think is our server about it's
actually an attacker called response.
We will again have a problem because inner
HTML is a DOM sync, then we have a bug.
I’m sure you are thinking about what I said
before which is no-one really writes code
that uses inner HTML directly anymore, so
this is
sort of a fake example right?
Yes it's a fake example, but what ends up
happening much more common in practice, is
that rather than using inner HTML directly
what you end up doing is instead of using
inner HTML you use some of the jQ lite rappers
that let you create part of the DOM your JQ
lite is a sub-set you just get some of these
convenience methods eye HTML, append and others,
and in here if you get the data from the attacker
and then you call append, this is sort of
in visibly wraps round the inner HTML DOM
sync, and you might have a problem.
So in the past, if I were a security engineer,
reviewing the code of a JavaScript application,
I would grab for an inner HTML, crap for a
bunch of these other patterns, but in here
we have angular and any other framework like
that injecting their own wrappers that do
the same thing but are sort of hard for both
the security engineer and the developer writing
the code to understand, that they are potentially
dangerous.
There's no big list that you can Google and
sort of know that these function calls are
dangerous.
So you just sort of have to keep that in mind.
We're almost done, I just have a couple of
things to show you that are maybe a little
less used but also interesting from the sort
of new way of doing things perspective.
So angular and other frameworks give you direct
access some of the interesting parsing functionality
that the framework has to do.
So rather than create a bit of HTML sort of
statically then in invoking angular on it
you can create a string on JavaScript then
call interpolate and angular will do the same
thing it would normally do on your page substitute
data bindings, render HTML the same thing
as compiling.
If you parse any untrusted data to any of
those function if you manually need to call
them for some reason you will also have another
cross-site scripting bug.
The final example that I wanted to show you
is something that Anand also mentioned earlier,
and that is probably the most common thing
that is like to happen in angular applications
in the past if you wanted to render some HTML,
that the potential lay has JavaScript attributes
or things that might be dangerous in some
way, but if you trust it you control all the
input you can say ngbinding HTML safe it will
be fine but this a dangerous API because any
time you pass user controlled data to it you
will have a bug.
Now angular actually prevented this from happening
in new versions, so now you just a have ngbindHTML
which will by default sanitise all the markup
you give the if you give it a script it will
escape everything if you give it a bold tag
it will keep it because it's knows it's safe.
There's a whole family of functions that let
you trust bits of data as HTML, basically
tell angular this fine don't worry about it
don't escape it I have checked it's correct.
This tends to be used improperly as scary
with scary frequency.
All right, ok.
So, like what's the point of all this?
What I thought initially as I was working
on this talk I thought ok I will try to scare
you a little bit, and then I will give you
solutions for all these things because why
wouldn't
I?
I don't want to be a jerk I want to tell you
how to write secure code, but in the end I
decided I will probably be a little bit of
a jerk and not tell you how to fix it and
the reason is that even if I told you how
to address all these patterns, that that we
saw on the previous slides it would not comprehensively
cover all of the sharp edges of the framework
that you might need to be concerned about.
So you would come out of this room thinking
ok I know everything there is to know about
angular security I will avoid these thing
it will be fine, but in practice it's not
like that because first of all angular is
just one of many frameworks and second of
all, there are many other things in angular
that we don't yet know about the framework
changes, so instead of giving you specific
recipes or patterns for how to avoid it I
will ask you to do 3 things, sort of to keep
in mind at a high level.
First of all, read the box.
I know as developers we often want to get
things running there's a lot of pressures,
but if you want to have a secure application,
usually what will really had is read the docks
from your framework they will tell you what
you have to keep in mind or what you have
to worry about.
The second thing is talk to security people,
either in person or on Twitter, ask them I’m
using angular what should I be worried about.
Because they, we as security folks get super
excited about these minute that led to thee
problems if you want to talk to me later I
am super happy to do it I love to do it.
That's second thing.
The third thing I want to leave you with is
I wanted to show you that these kind of things
can be, that interactions between these components
and the ways in which you can use new frameworks
are super cool exciting and it's fun to think
about it, and it's fun to break your on applications.
Next time you write code like this think about
whether it could possibly be vulnerable to
one of the things I showed and overall this
is just super fun.
I think it's almost as fun as HorseDrawingTycoon
kind of game.
With this I will leave it to Curtis who has
the next presentation about something that
I am sure you will not guess what it is.